Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
This is going to be my Guardians of the Galaxy
trailer Q&A; I've also got some Spider-Man
Homecoming trailer news. I saw an image that
said that the trailer was supposed to drop
during Agents of Shield's winter finale this
week; that's on Tuesday.
So, just be sure to subscribe to get that video.
Make sure you turn alerts on so that you don't
miss anything. They just got done showing
off footage of Brazil, Comic-Con.
So it would make sense that if they were gonna
drop the trailer with Star Wars Rogue One,
that they would get ready to drop it online.
Q&A though here we go first question
MushWorks asks: "I love how comic book accurate
mantis looks, and acts." The--the minor difference
that they made is just in her skin color and a
slight tweak to her origin story.
The thing about Mantis in the comics is that
there's been a bunch of different versions
of the character.
There was even a version of her that went
to DC comics for little while way way back.
But the most recent version, the one that we'll
talk about when we look at mantis here the
green skin one with the antenna, she was a
Cree experiment that debuted during Annihilation
Conquest. That was the storyline that formed
the Guardians. Like, that was the first time
the current version of the team came together.
She is an empath, like we see with that funny
clip at the end--you know with Drax laughing: "Do me
next, do me next!" The best example I can think
of that is Deanna Troy and her mother from
Star Trek: The Next Generation.
They're empaths; they can sense your emotions.
They can sense when you're feeling sad, or
happy, or anything. They
use her for comedy in the trailer but later
in the comics, Star Lord actually used it to
his advantage. Like, he used it to hypnotize other members
of the team to join up. So James Gunn just
explained too that the change in her appearance,
like the change in her skin, is just like the
way they changed Drax and Gamora. Like they
wanted them to all feel like very different
characters so they just changed the coloring.
So that's why Mantis is white and not green
like she is in the comics. Next question, KillZONE asks: "What if Nova were there because
he's part of the Guardians in the Ultimate Spider-Man.
So I think the reason that James Gunn said
he didn't want to put Nova in is just because
he's not a huge fan of the character... He doesn't
hate him, but he just wanted Peter Quill to
feel like he was alone in the galaxy was one
of the big things about the first movie is
that like they were all a bunch of people
without a family than they became a family
through the course of the film.
So that's why they all needed to feel like
outsiders and I think they also wanted to
try and avoid any Green Lantern looking stuff
like that's why they change Captain Marvel's
back story or they will change Captain Marvel's
back story whenever they do her movie, just
because the comic book version of the story
reads a lot like how Green Lantern got his
powers next question fuzzy bear asks I don't
know why Groot has learned how to speak yet.
Besides saying I am Groot book that it's just
part like the comedy of the character is that
he only can speak his name so just as I am
Groot we are Groot just variations of that.
A lot of you asked me to do a Groot videos
all totally do like a full bonus video on
Groot's origin story and where he's from,
but his race is Laura Colossus he's from planet
X the reason why he is so alone is because
he felt like an outsider amongst his own people
they call them saplings and he defended another
mammal and ended up killing another member
of his race.
So he was exiled that set him on the path
to beating rocket raccoon and the other guardians.
They didn't really address it in the trailer
but we see them walking around on that plan
with a bunch of trees around Groot is able
to control other plants we might get to see
them use his powers in a way that we haven't
seen before next question Lotta baby Groot
questions why does Groot have teeth.
Does he ever eat anything well he going mostly
just drinks water like you know plants with
drink, but the thing is I think they put teeth
on them just so they wouldn't freak little
kids out like it would look weird if it was
just like an open hole they wanted him to
feel like a tiny person so that you know I
paid extra attention to his facial features,
otherwise he be like a little coconut with
legs running around for a couple hours next
question Andrew asks about J'son of Spartax
was his father, and Captain Victoria was his
half-sister.
So the reason James Gunn explain this is because
he also wanted Peter Quill to feel like a
loner in the galaxy I think he was also not
a huge fan of the Jason as far tax in the
spar toy Empire.
So even though he wanted Peter Quill to feel
like this prince in the galaxy from this grand
heritage.
He wanted to use ego the living planet.
Just so that everybody would feel that much
more lonely next question Lorenzo asks.
I'm just hoping Adam warlock shows up you
and everybody else like ever since we saw
that cocoon.
The thing about Adam warlock is that he's
such a big deal in the infinity gauntlet storyline
in the comics but Marvel has taken things
in such a different direction that it sounds
like were not can a see him during infinity
war because you have to set his character
up you have to explain why is important what
the relationships are in the area.
So many characters.
So I think if we see Adam warlock in the movies
will only see him in the guardians movies.
And it'll be at Easter egg level James Gunn's
been back and forth about whether or not he's
going to do another guardians film after this,
but I do think that he'll do it he says he
has an idea for it but it might not happen
until phase 4 or even phase 5, so is not like.
They would roll right into production of that
next question Gabriel asks guardians three
should have Iron Man in it at least of James
Gunn is not directing you said just to keep
it interesting.
I don't do that Marvel would want to do a
guardians movie without James Gunn so I don't
think we have to worry too much about that
that is like the horror story where like a
really awesome director that make something
blow up and turns into this beautiful thing
goes away and then it all just goes to shed.
I don't think that Marvel would want that
even though guardians is a really big popular
franchise they want to make more guardians
films.
I think it would just wait until James guns
ready to make another one, even if it takes
a long time next question Jordan asks I wonder
if Groot will slowly get bigger and bigger
through the movie but I think the thing is
is that he'll stay tiny for like in a really
tiny for most of the film and then towards
the end there might be some big moment where
he grows up a lot of it has to do with him
wanting to grow up to the way James guns talked
about this version of Groot is that he's really
rambunctious very rebellious, but it doesn't
seem like he's in a rush to grow up so they
will probably be some moment in the film like
where he sacrificed himself in the first film
where he finally decides these people need
me to do something that I can only do if I
were an adult.
So be very surprised if he doesn't corrupter
in the film, but if you can imagine infinity
war with the guardians crossover in Robert
Downey Junior trying to deal with the tiny
baby Groot they might try to keep him small
for that next question Dante lead us why can't
all Marvel movies look.
This colorful and vibrant the color grading
on most Marvel films is so bland and muddy
this looks amazing.
So, the thing about that is a lot of criticisms
about the way Marvel chooses films but it
has to do with those like the types of cameras
that use James Gunn you something very different
this time.
Even if you're not a camera geek like this
is like the brand-new state-of-the-art red
weapon 8K camera.
This is one of the best cameras that money
can buy right now like they just started shipping
them to everyone else they shot guardians
last year, so number of filmmakers, including
James Gunn were given special versions of
these cameras to try out before they were
available to the public, so that getting in
the color science and like the mechanics of
the actual cameras is is a pretty fascinating
they're basically just much better than the
cameras that Marvel has been using on its
movies next question Andrew asks I to wait
five months for this, so the thing is is this
actually a bunch of other comic book movies
dropping before guardians, there's a whole
bunch of stuff happening in the beginning
of the year.
Lego Batman is actually like one of the first
big comic book movies coming out that's in
February like the beginning of February you
may have seen the trailer for if you saw a
movie in the theaters in the last week or
two Wolverine three the Logan movie is right
after that if the beginning of March and guardians
of the galaxy is right at the beginning of
May then wonder woman is right after that
there's actually a lot of stuff happening
at the beginning of the year so it will go
by a lot quicker than you think it would next
question wrapped asks is nebula gonna join
the guardians if she is didn't she die last
time when she didn't die she just lost a couple
limbs and then barely got away but I would
say that she's going to become a member of
the guardians, but she is supposed to travel
with them for brief.
Family is an important idea in the film Camorra
nebula are sisters to both daughters of Sandoz,
so they can have some fun playing with that
in the film but I think the idea is that she's
less straight up evil than she was in the
first film like imagine the relationship between
Thor and Loki Loki is kind of a villain, but
not always, it's a bit of a gray area is kind
of ambiguous sometime.
So I'm expecting the same treatment from nebula
and Camorra next question Simon asks, so is
Vin Diesel still playing Groot that he still
did the voice but obvious that they modulated
so that sounds like it's coming out of a really
tiny person, you probably could've hired any
kind of voice actor to do a Groot voice, but
I think the idea is that if he might grow
big in the film he would need to have that
Vin Diesel Groot voice, so that's probably
why they brought him back.
But, but he essentially spoke all the lines
that he needed to speak and then they change
the voice to make it sound like it was coming
out that teeny tiny little mouth next question
Danny asks who is wonder man so assume you're
talking about, Nathan Filion, so that you
of the characters play in the movie seems
just like a normal actor but wonder man in
the comics is actually this really weird story
he's kind of this big avenger that they can't
really use anymore because of IP rights, the
biggest story in the comics.
Most people remember about wonder man is that
they use his brain waves in his personality
matrix to revive vision, so he got his powers
in this chemical accident with Barron's IMO
but he's affectively about as strong as Thor
and way back during Stanley arrow Marvel there
was this big copyright fight with DC comics
because of the wonder woman character so Stanley
just agreed to never use wonder man again,
so wonder man still exists in the marvel universe
just don't expect to see him.
A whole lot.
Thank you everybody for 70 questions is always
a ton of fun to do all start doing more Q&A's
I will do a Spider-Man trailer Q&A whenever
that drops this week.
So leave all your questions and I'll say congratulations
to this giveaway winner Rasheen Roo you and
a $30 comixology giftcard there will be a
new round of the Spider-Man giveaway.
The next time I post tomorrow video just remind
everyone when I post that but there should
be game of thrones later today then walking
dead tonight Westworld others update people
on the schedule as I post new videos while
you guys wait for that to post you can click
here to rewatch the guardians trailer and
you can click here for my breakdown of that
Spider-Man homecoming footage they showed
off a couple days ago, thank you so much watching
everybody high five I'll see you guys tonight!